Not many weapons in the Star Wars galaxy
can hold up to a lightsaber — but there's
little reckoning with the few that can. So
who's got the tools to bring down a Jedi?
The Blade of Talzin is a robust-looking,
ornamental sword that looks like a cross
between a Japanese katana and a saber.
This weapon has something of a history
in the Star Wars universe. Mother Talzin is an
important antagonistic figure in The Clone Wars,
one who proves to be a physical force to be
reckoned with when she takes on Jedi Master
Mace Windu. For this purpose, she conjures
Talzin's Sword, an eerie-looking blade that
radiates green magical ichor and proves to be
on par with Windu's iconic purple lightsaber.
It's a neat trick really: The fact that Mother
Talzin can nigh-instantly summon a sword that's
able to match a lightsaber means that she
doesn't need to carry a weapon. Instead,
she can simply create one when necessary, which
makes it next to impossible to disarm her. What's
more, Nightsisters can use their magical
ichor to create all sorts of solid objects,
which means that the Blade of Talzin in
Ahsoka may refer to Talzin's technique of
summoning a sword instead of the object itself
— hence, its slightly different appearance.
A magic blade doesn't need to be carried
around and there's no technology to maintain,
which makes it far more useful than a lightsaber.
If there's a drawback to this particular weapon,
it seems to be fairly difficult to summon
— what takes Talzin a mere moment clearly
requires concentration from the three
Great Mothers. Still, since the Clone
Wars villain clearly has enough mystical
juice to create a lightsaber-level weapon
when the situation so requires, Talzin's Sword
more than earns its place in Star Wars legend.
The Blade of Talzin isn't the first weapon Morgan
Elsbeth has used against Ahsoka Tano. Their
first meeting in The Mandalorian culminates in a
samurai-style showdown, during which Morgan wields
a very nice-looking metal spear. As Ahsoka soon
finds out, this weapon is made of high-quality
beskar, the Mandalorian steel that's resistant
to just about anything — including lightsabers.
Much like in Ahsoka, Morgan's actual fighting
skills are no match for her opponent,
although that's not her weapon's fault.
The beskar spear is more than able to
match the lightsabers, and its weight and
reach make Morgan's attacks particularly
dangerous. She even manages
to partially disarm Ahsoka.
This scene makes it clear that a
beskar weapon has the potential
to be very dangerous to a lightsaber user.
"This is the way."
What's more, the metal can be used to
make all sorts of objects and equipment;
Morgan's spear is just one of the many possible
beskar melee weapons. For instance, the Armorer
from The Mandalorian uses her beskar gravity
hammer and tongs to deadly effect in combat,
and the Star Wars "Legends" lore
makes mention of a traditional,
machete-style short sword known as beskad, which
is often dual-wielded with a dagger called a kal.
Apart from its sheer versatility,
pure beskar also has one additional
advantage over the legendary Jedi weapon:
Lightsabers are unable to damage beskar armor…
but good beskar weapons have no such problem.
Star Wars often presents masked soldiers
as simply disposable cannon fodder. The
elite Praetorian Guard is a notable exception to
this rule, however. Known for guarding Supreme
Leader Snoke's throne room in The Last Jedi, the
imposing, red-armored First Order supersoldiers
are clearly bad news from the get-go — and
that's before you even see their melee arsenal.
The Praetorians wield various exotic weapons
that have been fitted with electro-plasma blades
that enable them to withstand lightsaber strikes.
These include a brutal-looking blade staff known
as vibro-voulge, as well as a bisento spear,
a nasty chain whip, and a vibro-arbir blade
that can be used as two separate weapons
or a single one with blades on both ends.
The Praetorian Guard is ultimately no match
against the powerful duo of Rey and Kylo Ren,
but it's a far closer fight than most battles
against masked goons in the Star Wars universe.
A lot of this has to do with the villains'
weapons, which they cleverly use on several
occasions to make their opponents' lives extremely
difficult. The chain whip, in particular, manages
to temporarily incapacitate Rey's lightsaber
in a way that could easily have killed her.
The First Order-era Praetorian Guard is an
evolution of the Imperial Praetorian Guard,
members of which have been known
to wield similar custom weaponry.
Judging by the fact that they take
down Paz Vizsla in The Mandalorian,
the franchise clearly wants fans to know
that these guys are no pushovers, either.
When The Force Awakens brought the
Skywalker saga back to the big screen,
few people could have expected that one
of the most glorious moments in the movie
would come courtesy of a random, angry First
Order stormtrooper. You remember the scene:
Finn wields a lightsaber in battle against
his former comrades on Takodana. Suddenly,
one of the stormtroopers loudly calls him a
traitor, dramatically throws away his blaster
and riot shield, and whips out a huge high-tech
melee weapon. He then proceeds to fight Finn — and
it quickly becomes clear that the trooper's
weapon can withstand lightsaber blows. Finn
is actually nearly defeated in this fight, before
Han Solo turns up and, inevitably, shoots first.
"Laugh it up, fuzzball."
The trooper in question is known as FN-2199, and
the weapon that cemented the fact that lightsabers
aren't the be-all and end-all of Star Wars melee
combat is a Z6 riot control baton. Amazingly,
these non-lethal weapons are standard issue
fare for First Order riot control stormtroopers,
which explains why FN-2199 happened to
be carrying a lightsaber-level baton
around. It also heavily implies that
there are many others like him around.
Of course, Finn's not exactly an expert lightsaber
duelist at this point, and no one's saying that
a well-trained Jedi couldn't hold his own
against a baton-wielding stormtrooper. However,
the fact that such low-level First Order grunts
have ready access to this level of gear suggests
that weapons like this are mass-produced fare —
unlike lightsabers, which are notoriously few and
far between. The combination of this weapon's
comparatively wide availability and its proven
combat-worthiness against lightsabers arguably
makes the riot control baton the superior product.